hey phoebe hi how are you hello
i'm good how are you uh i'm good now uh
i'm thrilled that i get a chance uh to
talk to you because you are the woman of
the moment this is a huge deal so uh i
mean just first of all congratulations
thank you thanks so much yeah it's been
surreal a few weeks
yeah it's so fascinating because
richardson came out
was it three four weeks ago it just came
out yeah so exactly pretty much exactly
four weeks ago it came out on christmas
day okay so this is what i experienced
it came out christmas day about two days
later everybody i know was texting me
and saying have you seen bridgeton and i
said that was two days two days two days
everybody and then uh
you know i said i'm going to watch it
give me a second
um
i hear doctors are like leaving
mid-operation to go watch bridgerton
everybody's gone mad for the show
and uh deservedly so it's a terrific
show but it's kind of a mania i don't
know what it's like in uh in britain in
the uk but here in america
people have lost their minds it's great
yeah it's amazing it's so and it's so
lovely to be part of something that's
obviously you know bringing a lot of joy
to people's lives and this
really crazy time so it's just it's good
to be part of something positive i guess
yeah it's very positive uh everybody
looks gorgeous the costumes are stunning
i think it's a nice
and there's so much about it too
that i think is fascinating uh
one of the things i'm curious about is
people talk today about
dating and how difficult it is with the
apps with the social apps and what a
weird experience it is
and i'm curious if
you almost do you prefer
i mean obviously there's a lot of
downsides but are there things that you
prefer about the way they were doing it
in the 19th century i mean you know i
mean
yeah i think the problem today is that
there is no social etiquette so you can
ghost someone and just sort of blank
them completely and there's no you know
there's no repercussions to that so
that's something you have to deal with
and also you know if if someone was into
you in those days
they would come around and bring you
a big bouquet of flowers it was pretty
much as simple as that so you knew where
you stood with people i think that's the
that was the benefit of being
a woman back in those days obviously
that's probably the only
yeah i was going to say
not many people were saying early 19th
century great time to be a woman
but um
but yes people had to put in an effort
they had to put in an effort and now
it's just someone can
um like something that you wrote or they
can send you an emoji and you think wait
a minute back then you had to ride
you know 80 miles through a bog
to deliver some roses it feels like a
guy had to work for it back then
they did yeah they did
um
but i think you know i think there's
there's a pluses and negatives isn't
there because also
if i'm not interested you know if
there's a nigel burbrook of today
i don't have to pander i can just say no
i'm good thank you yes
that's true i don't even have to say
thank you
[Laughter]
you don't even have to say anything you
just don't you just turn off your phone
for a week
exactly and maybe he gets the message uh
um i know i like that i like that a lot